[Music]
we're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty this week and joining me
today is an assistant professor of
philosophy politics economics and law at
the Jepson school of leadership studies
at the university of richmond jessica
flanagan welcome to the Rubin report hi
how are you doing well yeah let's learn
the Liberty it's kind of funny we're
gonna talk about a whole slew of things
here but medical ethics are involved and
at them as we are taping this at this
very moment there is a massive wildfire
about 45 minutes from the smoke and soot
outside right now that's even seeping
into the studio at the moment I was just
sneezing right before we started I can
feel it in my lungs are you feeling it
at all yeah no it's pretty intense out
there yeah you were you were gonna walk
here from the hotel which is only about
four blocks away and you were like no
yeah I bailed so there's something about
medical ethics or something with smoke
and fire or as you said right before you
serve maybe that's more environmental
ethics perhaps yeah I don't know what it
is out there but yeah it's a lot it's
alright alright so we're gonna talk all
sorts of things but let's start with
medical ethics we talk a lot about
health care in America and there's this
sort of endless crazy debate about Obama
care and Trump care and all single-payer
and all the buzz words and phrases what
do you think we're really missing when
it comes to the general health care
debate or what do you think of the tenor
of the health care debate in general I
think a lot of what people focus on in
the health care debate is with regards
to access with health insurance like
health insurance we have single-payer
with free market healthcare and I think
that's an important debate and that's
been the focus of a lot of political
philosophy and a lot of political
conversation about health care but one
thing I think we overlooked our kind of
clinical ethics like the ethics of what
happens and within that clinical context
within the system setting aside who pays
for it how we pay for it
things like pharmaceutical regulation
drug policy public health issues so I
think that a lot of times people will
sort of
think about Public Health more in an
instrumental way of like how do we
promote the public health like what's
gonna save lives and balance in terms of
Public Health policy but not asking the
broader question of should we be
involved in thinking about public health
as the kind of thing that public
officials should be promoting so those
are some things I think are overlooked
so things like regulation public health
ethics criminal justice and health like
how those two areas of policy intersect
and the clinical context informed
consent and self medication things like
that things that happen in the doctor's
office yeah so I want to dive into all
of those things for sure so in terms of
just the the general idea of healthcare
are you for having the government have
people buy into the exchanges and all
that one thing to say about the United
States system is like here's like a
place where like everybody can totally
agree like this is not the ideal system
I think you might add but this is not a
good system yeah whatever your favorite
system is I think this is like like a
non-ideal non-ideal solution yeah like
very robustly but is there a system that
you look at elsewhere and say there
they're really doing it right I mean not
really I think that a lot of other
systems have advantages and
disadvantages that we could learn from I
think that it's sort of a weird
historical accident that we have this
crazy Rube Goldberg of a health care we
have here I think that Australia may be
on the right track and having like a
kind of basic minimum but then like
markets on top although I don't my
impression is that they don't really do
like drugs the way that I would like
with respect to allowing more price
competition in pharmaceuticals but I
kind of favor a more market-based
approach is my own view um but again
because we have a global marketplace
like the markets themselves are like not
ever gonna be necessarily what like your
ideal of a market would be for
healthcare yeah but so you the first
question you asked was like should the
maybe requiring people to buy health
insurance yeah I don't think that they
should I think that how having health
insurance fits into you know a person's
values isn't really a choice that a
public officials like well-placed to
make for everybody it might be the case
that you know people don't benefit
dollar per dollar for health insurance
as much as they do for just having the
money and so I think like a good
benchmark for like is this a good policy
is would a person benefit more if you
just gave them the money instead of like
spending the money on them or requiring
them to spend the money on a certain
things from their own money on a certain
thing I also have written elsewhere
about so that's like about individual
mandates or individual requirements to
pay into health care systems
mmm in particular I've also written
elsewhere about like employer mandates
so should employers be required to pay
for health insurance if they're if they
have more than 50 employees for the
employees I don't think so
where does the 50 number come from I
think that's just in the Affordable Care
Act it's like it was at the I don't know
how it being implemented now but it was
about the time that I wrote that paper
about it right so the implication being
that if you're if you're that big at
that point then it's something that the
government should handle
know that then they could mandate that
employers provide health insurance to
that older 50 yeah larger employers and
I think well one thing I think is that
freedom of contract is an important
freedom and I think that when the
government says oh you and I we could
negotiate a contract but the contract
has to contain certain terms like a
certain wage or a certain provision of
benefits I think that would violate
individual people's freedoms of contract
and so I think people should be able to
make labor agreements under whatever
terms they want for the most part and so
the requirement that the government
could say like well you have to pay
people in health insurance and that bad
requirement would fall on people who are
employing people who are already
benefiting them much more than any other
random people in the community are
benefiting there these employees I think
that that would be a violation of
Fremont contract so yeah I'm sort of
against both yes I am against the
individual and employer base mandates
because I think that we should trust
people to decide
what in the cut and their contracts are
in their personal spending choices are
best for them yeah so in a weird way as
as at least a one-time Obama voter right
you voted for Obama at least one yeah
yeah that sort of puts you a little bit
at odds with Obamacare though we're not
a little bit that kind of really puts
you at odds with Obamacare yeah no yeah
so is that something you really
struggled with as you were voting for
him
cuz right I mean that's really the
landmark piece of legislation right I
mean that's yeah that's the thing that
he'll most likely be remembered for the
most yeah I think you know why do people
vote the way they do I mean a lot of
reasons but no I disagree with the
Affordable Care Act right yeah so did
you make any sense of when they were
trying to pass Trump care or whatever
his version of did you know or now even
they're scaling back little bits of it
or they're defunding parts of it it's
hard to pay attention or not even pay
attention it's hard to track actually
what the real world resolution is with
this stuff did did you see any goodness
in any of that that they were scaling
back some of it I mean who's changing
like every week it wasn't hard to even
keep up when that was that health care
debate was happening my impression was
that it was worse for people in that it
like didn't really solve the fundamental
objections people had to the Affordable
Care Act but then it created other
problems in the markets and the
exchanges but so what so what are you
doing cases of if you let it completely
free market and you didn't have
companies have to do anything under 50
over 50 whatever it is what do you do
for all the people that will just be
left behind I mean all the people that
were just going we're either just
flat-out dying because they weren't
seeing a doctor yeah or the people that
were then going to emergency rooms which
we know the costs of doing that are
actually way higher than if they had had
you know care when when they should have
what's the free-market sort of answer to
that yeah it depends on whether or not
so oftentimes people will say health
care is our right and what do you mean
by that Bernie says another thing do you
think a right is all right I believe it
what do you mean by right so you might
think that
a right is always enforceable if
somebody has a right to something then
they have a right against other people
to provide it to be clear you don't
think it's a right I don't think right
well I just think it depends on what you
mean by right right but I mean I don't
write I mean we have the right to life
liberty the pursuit of happiness really
the right the Bill of Rights yeah I
don't think there's anything in there
that says you have the right to health
care certainly not an enforceable right
right that other people provide you with
it I'm skeptical of that claim and so
what would it mean for there to be an
enforceable right to health care what
would it mean for their beauty right
that you had to claim that another
person provide it with you well it means
that you could use the enforcement power
of the state public officials could use
their enforcement power to compel other
people to provide their compete reott
swith health care and then my question
about that is why health care like why
is the thing that people are required to
be providing their compatriots health
care and not something like a basic
income which I do support income or they
could kind of decide how to allocate
their resources themselves in accordance
with our own value or providing people
with something like a basic standard of
well-being and then like if you won
until I provide people with a you know
set standard of well-being a set of
opportunities and health outcomes it's
not clear that like having them buy
health insurance or have health
insurance would be the thing that would
promote that mmm-hmm so it doesn't even
seem like health care is there it's like
health insurance is the thing that
people are saying is they're right and
so in order to establish that there's an
enforceable right for the public
officials to compel people to fellow
citizens to provide other people with
health insurance it would have to be
that health insurance in particular was
this thing that was so important for
like human autonomy flourishing and
well-being that it could warrant like
coercively you compelling people to
provide it now once we have that as our
bar like it was like this is the bar
like I think a lot of other things we
clear such a bar before health insurance
would I think it look like why for
example well a basic income for one I
think that like having some kind of
floor of material security we probably
so basically once you've said this is
right that we should have there's a
whole bunch of other things that using
that standard you think would be on the
list before health insurance right and
so if you think that there's an
enforceable right that people should
have health care you'd have to explain
in virtue of what do other people make
themselves liable to be coerced by the
government in order to provide their
fellow citizens with that right mm-hmm
in virtue of what value and whatever
value that is I would worry that there's
like a lot of other stuff we do putting
on the list before health insurance yeah
if they're also like a part of it that
it almost oddly sets people up against
each other in a weird way so if you take
good care of yourself and you exercise
and you eat right and you pay into the
system and you're healthy but then you
know you go to the supermarket and you
see someone buying a ton of soda and
eating horrible foods that's overweight
never exercising but you know that
they're gonna be more of a strain on the
system than you and you're basically
paying for them you know and so it's
sort of it would make you sort of almost
angry at people for not taking care of
themselves because they there then
expending the resources that you're
putting into the system because you're
living better so to speak I do think
that there is sort of a link between
support for like kind of spreading
across the house of health care and
support for public health to turn ilysm
I think that and I think that is the
link which is that people think that if
they're paying taxes to support programs
that are going to provide health care
for people then that gives them an
entitlement or a stake in the health of
other people right but then think it
through so say that you do think that
health care or health insurance is an
enforceable right then everybody has a
right to it no matter what mm-hmm then
people don't make themselves
preemptively liable to have their other
liberties limited on the grounds that in
virtue of their choices or permissible
choices they're gonna make it more
expensive to enforce those rights so by
that I just mean like say that you're a
person that just wants to eat like
Doritos and coca-cola you're all day
which is delicious
why do you college I'd be sympathetic I
do that you know and then people say
well like no you can't just do that or
you can't smoke cigarettes because if
you do then we're all gonna have to pay
for it well then you might say like but
wait a minute
like who cares like you have an
obligation in virtue of my enforceable
right to pay for it anyhow and so like
you don't get to tell me what to do just
because subsequently you're going to
have to give me what I'm owed which is
high health care if you owe me $50 and
you don't like how I'm gonna spend the
$50 you don't get to write you know tell
me to change my behavior before you give
me the $50 I just think it could it's
not an enforceable concept but it's just
I think it would just cause resentment I
think in general like if you're just
like I don't I don't expend a lot from
the system I don't take a lot from the
system and here are other people that do
it's just sort of human nature I think
to resent like yeah just sort of resent
it yeah yeah yeah maybe I mean I don't
think that they should if they really
think that they have a duty to provide
it right well I don't know that people
really think it through all the way and
maybe a certain amount of people don't
think they have a duty to provide yeah
don't think I would provide it their
issue isn't with the people eating
Doritos and smoking cigarettes their
issue is with being forced to provide
other people with health insurance it is
you know a different gripe so either way
you don't have any kind of grounds to
present or to want to limit the freedom
of the people who just want to smoke
cigarettes named Doritos because like
which I feel like I'm like hating under
readers it's not about everybody loves
the Cool Ranch
yeah right but um so I feel like you
know if you're a person who thinks
health care is our right then you have
no grounds to want to limit the choices
to those people because you buy your own
life think that you have a duty to
provide them a health care whatever
their choices are right and if you're
you know irritated by people making
public you know making choices that
could be prevented with public health
paternalism that you disapprove of all
on the grounds that you don't want to
pay for their health insurance then
what's doing the work is really just
that you don't want to pay for their
health insurance and so then you also
don't have any real beef with people
making bad health decisions right and so
either side I don't
should support public health paternalism
interesting you know you mentioned
cigarettes a couple times it's funny
because literally my chest is tight
right now I don't smoke cigarettes but
from the smoke outside like I can feel
it at the end of this moment and I
always think the cigarette thing is kind
of interesting cuz I used to live in New
York City and I'm pretty sure cigarettes
for something like 12 or 15 dollars a
pack like taxed beyond imagination which
I always thought was was an odd thing
because it's like you're taking people
with this vice yeah and then you know
and an addiction a true addiction to
tobacco and all the other stuff that's
in there and then you're you're making
all of this extra money off it that the
government then needs to do whatever its
doing so it's like a doubly abusive
thing in a way not that you should just
be giving cigarette cigarettes away for
free but taxing these vices these
addictive vices you're just taking more
money from those people and putting it
now you're gonna need the government
never wants less money so it's never
gonna be like alright we're gonna lose
tax that lower or we're gonna stop
spending there is some evidence that
cigarette taxes do reduce smoking which
makes sense unless you think that
cigarette is like this cigarettes are
sort of this like uncontrollable
compulsion that people have which would
be interesting that and that if you
increase the price of it by a dollar
then people stop doing it right you're
saying to poor people then it's probably
poor people that men can't afford it so
then it's like well poor people
shouldn't be allowed to smoke cigarettes
which I think some people would have
that is the way it goes down I don't
know but I do think that sin taxes in
general are like cigarette taxes taxes
on things that the government doesn't
want people to do like soda taxes are
another example they are regressive for
sure I mean just because you know the
marginal value of that dollar is going
to be disproportionately the marginal
impact of being taxed an additional
dollar will be disproportionately
harmful to people who have less money
right and so we have these regressive
public health taxes that are gonna
disproportionately burden the
economically worse off and I also think
that they're very expressively harmful
because they express disapproval of
certain people's choices on behalf of
the government which it's not morally
wrong to smoke cigarettes it's not
morally wrong to drink soda and so I
don't think that the government should
be
expressing disapproval or limiting
people's rights to make choices that are
permissible right again I think there's
some sort of argument that says if the
government is gonna give health
insurance to everyone that maybe then at
the same time the government has a right
to tell you you should I don't agree
with this but I can see the argument
though that you all right the
government's gonna give you all the
dreads everyone well then why can't the
government say you know it and you can't
smoke cigarettes and you can't drink
soda with high-fructose corn syrup
because we know it's going to give you
diabetes which is also going to be a
strain on the system again I don't yeah
I agree with that
but I can understand that line of
thinking yeah if that were the argument
then I would think that then you should
let people opt out so it'd be like hey
free health insurance in exchange for
not smoking or drinking soda or exchange
for exercising or something I don't
think people would be on board with that
though I don't think that they would
like it if there was a policy of making
the provision of public services
conditional on people behaving right
you'd have a black market basically of
soda you know people would be secretly
smuggling so I mean what I was saying
was like you know maybe if people if
taxpayers like oh we don't want to pay
for people's health insurances are gonna
make these bad choices that still
doesn't justify banning the bad choices
because you could just say if you want
to get you know publicly subsidized
health insurance then you can't make
these bad choices then you can't smoke
or then you can't drink soda I don't
think people would accept that I don't
think people would say that that was
their ideal of a public and provide a
health insurance system where it's like
you know if you wanna where people would
have to voluntarily limit their liberty
in order to have access to it yeah I
don't think that most people who support
like Medicaid for all would support a
system where Medicaid for all but people
can opt out of it in exchange for the
right to smoke cigarettes right it's
interesting because I would always veer
on more choice and yet we find ourselves
at a place where it's like well people
are gonna do bad things and you're just
gonna sort of have to pay for it if we
have less choice it's just that it is
great so go through that argument again
that if you that if you have less choice
meaning the government is gonna make you
have health insurance or whatever it is
that people are going to do bad things
and you're gonna sort of have to
subsidize it it's just this Janet right
I mean
I'll be for banning it yeah yeah it's an
interesting thing I mean in the
cigarette one I think it's particularly
interesting because the government here
saying here's this is something bad we
all agree this is bad the government is
now going to make a lot of money off
something bad and it wants money so it
almost wants you to smoke cigarettes you
know yeah I don't know that the
government wants people but they want
that money and they know it's a way to
make money right I don't know that they
want I don't think they're sitting in a
thing going we got to get more people
smoking cigarettes yeah when they look
at the numbers and they're like wow look
at all this money we took in from
cigarettes I think they probably view
that as a good they want more money but
I think at the same time public
officials are definitely invested in
reducing long term health care cost and
reducing rates of smoking and so I mean
it's hard to like I think people often
use this idea where they're like the
government does this so like the
government does that but like there's
not one thing that like is like the
government right it's just public
officials with different kind of
motivations and so but I don't think
that many public officials are motivated
of like oh yeah let's raise money
through cigarette taxes I think that the
primary motivation of people who pass
the Grant taxes is to deter people from
smoking right but I don't think that
that's I don't even think that's a good
motivation I don't know which the
primary motivator
it's bad enough of it they're just like
oh we want to like cast judgment on
people's permissible choices in order to
discourage it like I think that that's
like I mean I think that's sinister
enough yeah if you want a reason to
oppose the cigarette taxes
yeah all right well I think we hit the
basics of sort of the main public policy
and stuff that I wanted to get to let's
talk a little bit about medical ethics
sorry in general define medical ethics
for me what people ought to do in
healthcare and medical contexts and you
want people to have more choices than
they currently have that's right yeah so
I wrote a book par mystical freedom yeah
christmas is coming makes it will have a
link in the description and the argument
for the book is that the same reasons in
favor of informed consent which is a
core principle of medical ethics are
also reasons in favor of rights of
self-medication yeah way let's do let's
define some of the terms so informed
consent is
is that physicians are not entitled to
make medical decisions on behalf of
their patients as long as their patient
is competent and patients have rights
against being coerced into making
particular medical decisions medically
competent patients are not children and
that it's also impermissible for
physicians or anyone else to deceptively
mislead or withhold information from a
patient in order to get them to make a
medically advisable decision how do you
actually figure out what informed means
what the word in four means I mean when
I've been to hospitals with grandparents
sort of at the end of life and when
they're trying to do the last few things
that they can do and they say well we
can do this or that or you know all
these different things they're
explaining it usually to you but you
don't really feel informed like you you
really don't know unless you're a doctor
yourself so how do you actually define
what informed really means is that the
patient should be informed up to this
kind of reasonable patient standards so
like what a reasonable person would deem
relevant to the content of their
decision and so that includes both
information about the risks and benefits
of particular treatment but also
information about treatment alternatives
and also information about the risks and
benefits of having no treatment of
declining treatment entirely so that's
the sort of broad standard of what level
of information is required for a patient
to have access to some patients might
want to not know certain information
this is becoming increasingly an issue
with things like information about
genetic risk factors for example and so
then patients should have the right to
also kind of consent to the uncertainty
perhaps and so say like well we could
disclose genetic risk factors from this
analysis unless you don't want to know I
think so in effect you then would be
opting out and then you're sort of
waiving any of your legal rights I
assume after I don't know what the legal
context is but I think morally patients
should be entitled to essentially
exercise as much control over the amount
of information they want with respect to
their medical choices and also to have
unrestricted access to whatever
information they would deem relevant to
their medical choices but the doctors
should be on the hook to provide
patients in the context of medical tests
decision with whatever information and
reasonable patient would want to know
about the risks and benefits of
treatment treatment alternatives and no
information there are no treatment right
but in it so in effect though you you as
a patient could say to your doctor there
are things that I will not want to know
and your doctor yeah my own view is that
that's true that lay patients should be
able to opt out of knowing although they
will have to agree an example of
something like that so I think that the
the primary example where this is an
issue is with testing for genetic risks
so if physicians know that a person has
a late-in-life risk of a certain disease
should the physician be required to
disclose it to the patient and I think
that the physician should be required to
disclose that the test might turn up
certain diseases and then ask the
patient if they want to know because
some people might prefer to live in
ignorance of that type of knowledge
that's controversial I'm at a suffix
whether or not patients should have a
right to know but informed consent is
less controversial outside of those
Martin those are kind of marginal cases
right it's like outside of those more
marginal cases we're all familiar today
with what informed consent requires so
you go to the doctor you say treatment a
treatment B what are the risks and
benefits of the two and the main idea of
informed consent is that you are the
author of your own medical choices
you're the person that's in the driver's
seat not the doctor and so the doctor
can't trick you mislead you withhold
information or coerce you in order to
get you to make a decision that the
doctor thinks is medically advisable it
didn't always used to be this way so the
emergence of informed consent happened
in the twentieth century before then
physicians were very paternalistic
towards people and even well into the
20th century so there was a survey done
in the late 60s of oncologist about
people who are diagnosed with cancer
whether or not they always accurately
revealed the diagnosis ninety percent of
con colleges said that they did not
always accurately reveal cancer
diagnosis to their cancer patients
meaning that they were no they would
withhold a diagnosis from patients
paternalistically for fear that the
diagnosis would be harmful to the
patients if they knew it
sometimes even
meeting in an alternative diagnosis and
it was 1968 1968 I think the study was
so bring out a little further what would
be the legitimate if you were an
oncologist and you knew that one of your
patients had cancer what would be the
argument for at the time they thought
that there was at least in some cases
the in colleges with those would
withhold or mislead patients about their
diagnosis on the grounds that they
thought that the information about the
diagnosis would be harmful to patients
Wow I mean that's incredible yeah but
yeah now we think that that sounds
bananas that was very recent so informed
consent has only robustly been with us
for the past 50 years or so in this way
and now it's baked in we all understand
like yes it is wrong for doctors to
mislead people or to lie to people about
their diagnosis it's wrong for doctors
to coerce people into accepting surgery
so the first informed consent case was
in 1912 1913 and it was a case where
doctors performed a hysterectomy on a
woman without her consent
she actually explicitly said that she
did not consent to surgery then she was
being examined under ether and the
doctors removed her organs that doesn't
happen yeah anymore when it does it's
like a big deal like it's not a battery
at the form of assault yeah
so we now think about patient choice and
people's control over their health in a
much more respectful way I think that's
been like a shine of moral progress like
I believe in moral progress in the
worlds you know capable of morally
improving I think this is one example at
the same time however across the
twentieth century
patients slowly lost rights of
self-medication
so while over the course of the 20th
century patients were gaining the
authority in the doctor's office to make
medical decisions for themselves they
were losing that authority at the
pharmacist and so the book is about why
the same reasons that give patients the
authority to make medical decisions
about their own bodies in the clinical
contacts are also reasons in favor of
giving people rights of self-medication
in the marketplace and in the
pharmaceutical so how did we lose
control of some of that related to the
pharmaceuticals
well there were a series of drug
disasters the first elixir sulphate of
IED in the 1930s and then that the lid
of my disasters in the 1960s which the
United States avoided because of a
regulator at the FDA who was very
cautious in approving the drug
application for at the lid abide those
drug disasters led and both health and
at both times for public outcry for
increased pharmaceutical regulation
first can you tell me a little bit more
about what the the drug actually was
yeah so lips are still fit amide um
sorry your fires outside I mean they're
really I'm feeling it right now we're in
a while we're doing this elixirs love it
of mine was essentially an anti in fact
in that was diluted with something like
antifreeze and it was distributed in the
1930s and when it was this drug was
diluted in this kind of anti freeze like
substance diethylene glycol a lot of
people mostly children died from taking
it and after the children died from
taking it there was a lot of media
coverage the drug was recalled there
were lawsuits but there wasn't really
much of a legal basis for punishing the
people besides the fact that it was
mislabeled mmm-hmm
and so there was public outcry against
the fact that this very dangerous
medicine was being distributed to people
and they didn't have an opportunity to
consent the initial drug regulations
that passed authorizing the FDA
stipulated that it was only intended to
make self medication safer and more
effective so in the 1900s
sprites of self-medication were widely
affirmed people believed in rights of
self medication and the initial
regulations that were passed were just
supposed to be like labeling
requirements making people could be
informed what they're taking
but the approval process quickly evolved
into a safety standard requiring pre
market safety testing in order to
establish that people knew what they
were getting when they're taking a drug
by the 1960s when the thalidomide
disaster happened which was a drug that
was used by pregnant women to treat
morning sickness and then it caused
miscarriages and then some children to
be born without limbs it mostly hit in
Europe and we avoided it because of our
approval process in the United States by
this time the FDA became a kind of model
for the world about drug regulation and
that still is true today so a lot of
other countries kind of mirror the
regulatory approach off of the FDA and
United States avoided it because of
regulatory caution with respect to a new
drug application but seeing the pictures
of the infants that are born without
limbs from lid amide there was once
again a great deal of public support in
the FDA past the Congress authorized the
FDA to enforce efficacy testing
requirements as well so now in order for
a drug to be brought to market it needs
to be shown that it is both safe and
effective before being brought to market
that sounds like a good idea
road to hell is paved with good intent
in you but now say that the FDA approves
the drug and it says you know we
fast-tracked this drug it got approved
very quickly we approved it you know
from basic research to approval five
years so to be very very fast and now we
expect it to save 10,000 lives here the
way that you should perhaps hear that is
that tens of thousands of lives were
lost during every year that approval for
the drug is withheld people see the
children who died during the elixir
still fitted my disaster the thalidomide
babies but people don't see the people
who look like they were dying of their
diseases but they were actually dying
because of regulatory caution because
they couldn't get access to drugs that
could potentially help yeah you don't it
doesn't it's not as vivid to us when
people die for a lack of access to drugs
mm-hmm but it really is the case that
though it looks like their diseases are
what's calling them was actually telling
them is the lack of access yeah so this
is kind of a tough place for someone
with certain libertarian leanings like
yourself to be in right because you kind
of you're acknowledging the FDA did some
good work in the first place here but
then that right like right I mean I
think you are I don't want to word to
you I thought you're acknowledging that
by having this regulation at first it
stopped it from coming to the United
States correct well I mean I don't even
think that necessarily because that the
approval process for the drug wouldn't
have even been for pregnant women most
pregnant women use drugs off-label I
think
people saw it as a win for the FDA
because the FDA didn't approve the new
drug application and so the United
States largely avoided the crisis but I
don't think that the current system
would have prevented a crisis like the
lid imide in the United States because
very few drugs are approved for use in
pregnant women and so it's like sort of
this weird story I don't know that we
should credit the FDA in this way for
like intentionally preventing that now
so like when you're like oh you credit
the FDA with certain things I do think
one thing the FDA does that is good is
that it enables inform patient choice it
certifies drugs so my view is like if
you like the FDA which I know a lot of
people do it's one of the most popular
regulatory agencies fine let it do
everything it does now let it certify
drugs like the Good Housekeeping Seal of
Approval I also think there should be
other certification C's for drugs it's
like when you go to a whole food and
there's like 15 different certifications
on all of your different you got a lot
of things on those boxes yeah what you
know let any drug have all sorts of
certifications but including as we have
with food like USDA like let them
certify drugs what I object to is the
FDA prohibiting drugs which they have
been doing for a long time and so what
you would holding access to drugs I
think violates people's rights it's a
violation of the rights to make
decisions about their own bodies yeah
are there any particular drugs at the
moment that they're withholding that you
think are real game changers I mean it's
always hard to know I mean that's the
reason that they do withhold it is
because there is high uncertainty for
unapproved drugs there's also high
uncertainty for approved drugs mm-hmm
but yeah I wanted to ask you about that
actually because everyone knows I mean
it's it's a joke that everybody makes
you turn on the TV you watch any
commercial half the commercials these
days or for prescription drugs they tell
you a little something good about it at
the beginning where the guys running in
the field and everybody's happy and he's
on a mountain and then the
three-quarters of the commercial really
are about the diarrhea and upset stomach
and thoughts of suicide and restless leg
syndrome and blindness and a kajillion
other things so something seems wrong
with the way we are medicate
our selves or the way that these things
get passed it's almost as if our bodies
are telling us not to be on half of this
stuff not to say I have friends that are
on different things and I had a friend
that was really helped by lithium and a
bunch of other things but that there's
some odd thing that we're doing with
overmedicating or that that we push this
stuff on ourselves constantly whether or
not a person should use any kind of a
drug is a decision that should just be
made in terms of the risk-benefit
calculus for their own life as a whole
and who's the expert about your life as
a whole you are and so what happens with
the FDA is that they impose these
broad-based judgments that apply to
everybody when they prohibit a drug or
withhold access to a drug before
approval that say that the drug is
unacceptably risky and then when they
approve a drug they say this drug goes
approved because the risks are
acceptable in light of the benefits now
that's not a scientific judgment that's
not a judgment that the FDA is
well-placed to make whether or not
something's acceptable risky is a
normative judgment it's a judgement what
you should do with your own life in your
own body so medical experts doctors
pharmaceutical regulators public
officials are not experts about whether
or not something's acceptable rescue the
person who's an expert about whether
it's except typically rescues the
patient now you seem to be saying like
well patients are taking too many risks
like they're they're using too many
drugs well it seems like we're inundated
with so much of this that everyone I
mean I think we're the most over
medicated country in the world I'm not
you can correct me if I'm wrong but I
think it's something like I don't think
isn't it illegal for some of these
commercials to be on all the time in
Europe I'm pretty sure they have laws
against some of this stuff and yet for
us we're slammed with it constantly and
I think that that causes your ability
but that's bad that there's so much
pharmaceutical advertising I'm not for
over-regulation so this is one of the
places where it's it's a struggle right
like I'm trying to be intellectually
honest here I'm not for over-regulating
these things and I'm always for more
choice so I understand the argument but
the general allow me but the general the
general idea that were slammed with so
much of us that it makes your ability to
make a clear minded choice more
difficult and we're going to talk about
critical thinking a little more then
because I think that well I'm in favor
of direct-to-consumer
marketing which the United States is one
of only a few countries that allow it
and I think that's good I think that's
like part of our sort of strong
commitment to freedom of speech that we
do include commercial speech to an
extent within that and I think that if
the government were to say no
pharmaceutical advertising that that
would be a content-based restriction
against speech that advocates in favor
of lawful conduct on the grounds that
the government doesn't approve the
message yeah so I'm not worried about
that free speech guy so I'm not against
it I just think our ability I don't know
what the answer is I'm just saying that
our ability to make informed choices
about the drugs that they are pushing us
pushing on us all the time seems to be
very slippery
just maybe we have that slippery ability
because we haven't been given the
autonomy to make decisions about our own
health maybe it's a kind of learned
helplessness from the fact that
currently you know people aren't aren't
authorized to make choices about their
own health so we have a prescription
requirement system where you have to go
to a doctor and got the prescription
maybe people offload it to physicians
and then they accept more risk than they
otherwise would because they think well
if a doctor would have prescribed it
then it's fine
and then the physicians have this other
way of looking at we're like well if the
patient wants to take it like the risk
is on her and it could lead to more
risky decision making there's some
evidence from an economist from the 70s
who did research on this and peltzman
that prescription requirements actually
induced more risky decision making and
resumed higher rates of accidental drug
poisonings because of this sort of
offloading effect where people think
that if a doctor told you it was okay to
take it that it's okay to take it so
that's really interesting to me the
right cuz they're like I the doctor said
it's okay so I'm gonna go ahead and do
it I don't even have to listen to the
people telling me that I'm gonna have
diarrhea and thoughts of suicide and all
the rest of it where people are yeah
they take less they're less cautious
because they feel like their decisions
are authorized by first the FDA the FDA
approved it's an FDA approved drug and
by their doctors and so they're more
likely to take on risks associated with
you yeah so in an odd way by removing
some of these restrictions it would
actually strengthen the doctor you think
because the person would be on the
yeah - then take the responsibility for
themselves I mean I've talked to some
doctors about this and they kind of like
you might think the doctors be like oh
no we need to keep prescription
requirements but they think right now
you know look maybe I could focus more
on patient care you know maybe we could
you know focus more on really having a
conversation with patients who want
advice from a doctor I'm not saying
people shouldn't talk to their doctors
before making decisions about which
drugs to use I'm saying that after they
talk to their doctors the decision
should be in their hands and that if
they don't want to talk to a doctor
that's also their decision yeah well
you're also saying actually listen when
they list all of those side effects yeah
I think that like you don't even listen
to that part you know and it's why their
marketing is so good all these people
are having a great time while they're on
Valtrex
you know what I mean and then you find
out what what all the side effects are
but you don't really oh well that won't
happen to me you know yeah I think that
you know patients should have the
autonomy to take responsibility for
their health have the authority to make
decisions about themselves and they
should take that seriously and they
should educate themselves and I think
that also people they should have access
to the relevant information I don't
think that you know I would favor you
know
fair labeling requirements making labels
accessible for people to be able to
understand the risks and benefits of the
treatment but ultimately whether or not
a decision is acceptable risky whether
the risks outweigh the benefit no one
can make that decision for a patient
except for the patient yeah all right so
the through line here I think is more
choice fair to say I'm usually gonna be
in favor of more choice
[Music]
you